invités politiques c'est julien bayou
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts tête de liste pour les
régionales en île de france et vous êtes
avec nous pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane l'un des bons jours stéphane
bonjour rien qui dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest-france un mot
avant de parler de l'actualité nationale
sur l'actualité du week end
c'est ce qui se passe en biélorussie
l'union européenne qui a décidé hier
d'isoler la biélorussie elle a décidé de
fermer son espace aérien aux avions
biélorusse et demande aux compagnies des
27 états membres de ne pas le survoler
c'est une décision qui a été prise après
le détournement d'un avion de ligne
européen pour arrêter un opposant au
régime opposants dont l'union européenne
réclame d'ailleurs la libération
immédiate est ce que pour vous la
réaction de l'union européenne est
suffisante et à la hauteur en tout cas
elle et elle est proportionnée et elle
est allée concertée voilà moi je pense
enfin en tant qu'européens convaincu que
quand l'europe parle d'une seule voix
elle peut elle peut énormément et donc
là il s'agit vraiment de d'une agression
de la part de la vielle russie c'est
quand même du jamais vu depuis depuis
longtemps de détourner un avion pour
arrêter un opposant un journaliste et
donc c'est l'honneur de la de l'europe
que de répondre d'une seule voix il faut
maintenant continuer parce qu'il faut
obtenir la libération ce journaliste est
donc les sanctions doivent être
proportionnées et peut-être graduée
augmenter jusqu'à la libération de cette
de ce journaliste quand les sanctions
mais l'europe de se battre vraiment pour
la liberté de la presse sur son sol
parce qu'elle est souvent menacé
également on l'a vu avec malheureusement
la projet le projet de loi sécurité
globale qui risquait d'empêcher
deux films et de filmer des violences
policières le conseil constitutionnel
les a censuré de tant mieux l'europe
doit agir sur son sol et puis prévenir
protéger la liberté de la presse partout
y compris en biélorussie mais quand vous
mettez ça sur le même plan juste la loi
sécurité globale et ce qui se passe je
parle liberté de la presse et que donc
on doit agir pour protéger la liberté la
précédente sur quel plan de s'en prendre
aux options s'en prendre aux avoirs vous
avoirs financiers des désagréments que
juste par exemple soustrait ce serait
taper au portefeuille en effet les avait
d'abord un vous commencez à voir sa part
souvent souvent je ne suis pas expert de
la biélorussie donc je m'arrêterai là
mais souvent les hauts dignitaires de
ces régimes dictatoriaux ont beaucoup
d'avoir dans des banques ou patrimoine
immobilier dans les capitales
européennes et donc commencé par bloquer
ces avoirs me semble être une bonne
réponse on va parler de ce qui se passe
en france et cette plainte déposée par
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur plainte contre audrey pulvar
votre concurrente socialiste en région
ile-de-france en cause cette phrase
qu'elle a prononcé à propos de la
manifestation des policiers mercredi on
va la cité une manifestation soutenue
par l'extrême droite à laquelle
participe un ministre de l'intérieur qui
marche sur l'assemblée nationale c'est
une image qui pour moi était assez
glaçante et je ne souhaitais pas y
participer est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec cette phrase et que pensez-vous de
la plante de gérald darmanin évidemment
d'abord plein soutien à audrey pulvar
cette phrase n'a rien de diffamatoire
sont des faits vous avez un ministre de
l'intérieur qui a marché avec l'extrême
droite face au parlement pour en gros
avaliser des death langues qui disaient
la justice est laxiste donc le
l'exécutif et c'est devant les télés
nationales ces marchés sur l'assemblée
nationale pour ben oui parce que si
il fallait rendre hommage aux policiers
qui sont tombés pour nous protéger aux
personnes qui ont fait le sacrifice de
leur vie pour nous protéger mais dans ce
cas là cet hommage s'est organisée par
la préfecture c'est peut-être devant un
commissariat de police ou à eau à
beauvau quand vous faites un
rassemblement qui vire à la
manifestation devant l'assemblée
oui évidemment s'il s'agit de faire
pression il s'agit d'une manifestation
d'un timide ici d'intimidation et ça
n'était pas le rôle du ministre c'est à
dire l'exécutif que de se présenter face
au législatif dans des manifestations où
les slogans virait à l'accusation à
l'égard de la justice et et quelles
dérives on a le ministre de l'intérieur
qui invente une plainte qui tient
absolument pas debout 1 là encore de
l'intimidation vis-à-vis d'une candidate
socialiste
alors qu'on est à quelques encablures
des élections c'est le 20 juin et que le
rôle du ministre de l'intérieur c'est de
protéger la tranquillité de des
opérations de la campagne et des
opérations de vote
il a dit hier à marseille juste part de
ses fans de tintin il a dit hier à
marseille le débat électoral ne peut pas
se faire en crachant la figure des
policiers non mais attendez ça rendait
vraiment très très loin du compte
on a un gouvernement qui finalement
prend appui sur l'extrême droite
son rôle était de la combattre et en un
ministre de l'intérieur qui considère
que marine le pen était trop molle qui
manifestent avec l'extrême droite qui
s'en prend par contre avec une violence
inouïe aux écologistes
je pense à la polémique sur les cantines
scolaires le ministre de l'intérieur qui
pendant une semaine s'en prend au menu
sans viande à lyon parlant d' idéologie
dans l'assiette qu'est-ce qu'on n'a pas
entendu alors qu'il s'agissait de
garantir que 29 mille enfants puissent
avoir accès aux cantines scolaires voyez
pour ce gouvernement met d'ailleurs
c'est un peu le cas pour valérie
pécresse présidente de la de droite de
la région ile de france on a des membres
de la droite dite républicaine qui ce
qui se réfère aux gaullistes et qui nous
disent l'extrême droite n'est pas un
ennemi de la république l'extrême droite
c'est pas le danger le danger ce serait
une coalition d'écologistes qui viennent
mettre en oeuvre la rénovation thermique
et des pistes cyclabes où il ya il ne
sait pas du tout ce que dit gérald
darmanin lui dit qu on bat le
rassemblement national et cela est pris
en défaut et du son combat contre le
rassemblement dans les fêtes
pardon en camp combattent il
strasnoy des manifestes avec elle qu'il
n'ya pas cuit alors vers les jeux là vos
propos sont très claires et la position
du parti europe écologie les verts sur
cette manifestation était très clair on
n'y va pas le problème est que vous avez
yannick jadot qui est candidat à la
candidature pour la présidentielle au
nom d'europe écologie les verts qui
était comment du coup comment vous gérez
ça ben nous on n'y allait pas les
comprendre on a pris la décision quand
on a vu que finalement selon fait que
lui il s'est quand même un problème
quand je vois comment je vais ski fin il
comprend les personnes qui sont allées
pour rendre hommage si ça avait été un
hommage un rassemblement du lourd dit si
ça avait été un hommage alors que deux
personnes ont perdu la vie pour nous
défendre nous orienter les premiers sur
place évidemment mais oui mais vous
voulez mon avis vu le coût jours nous
avons pris des décisions qui dit on y va
pas au moment clairement ce sera pas
qu'un hommage et donc faut pas y aller
voilà pourquoi au moment où ils avaient
pris la décision nous avions tous les
éléments tels que ce quelques semaines
ou quelques jours avant c'était un
hommage et finalement en tout début de
semaine je crois vous avez suivi un
petit peu le déroulé sont sortis des
études avoir indications des des tracts
des appels finalement à critiquer la
justice allait devoir ça aussi et
yannick jadot il y allait pour rendre
hommage
voilà et évidemment qu'il ne souscrit en
aucun cas aux demandes de 2,2 de peines
plancher de peines automatiques sont
fait une une violation de l'état de
droit
quand vous dites le juge n'a plus à
prendre sa part dans la décision de
justice
en fait c'est ce qui nous distingue des
des régimes autoritaires évidemment
qu'il faut l'individualisation des
peines et
c'est très clair que ces peines
automatiques c'est pas une planche et
qui sont réclamés par l'ats la police et
qui finalement ne sert à rien vraiment
c'est pas parce qu'on pénalise quoi que
ce soit que on va réprimer les aie envie
damien mais la présence de yannick jadot
à ce rassemblement et débats entre vous
et ce qui est souvent ces sanctions
c'était une erreur mais je comprends je
comprends que des personnes aient baissé
pour vous oui au col en reste là ya pas
de ya les sympathies ça pas de
conséquence là on en a beaucoup discuté
et on a je trouve je vous le dis oui et
bien sûr mais n'a reconnu lui il dit
mais je comprends qu'il voulait rendre
hommage au policier et encore une fois
il y avait beaucoup de confusion
il y dit pas que ça oui il dit que les
écologistes ne peuvent pas être absents
des thèmes régalien ne peuvent pas être
absents des thèmes de la sécurité
doivent aussi répondre à la colère des
policiers
il dit qu'il ne faut pas laisser le
champ libre à l'est comment est ce que
vous croyez que le ministre l'intérieur
répond à quoi que ce soit du malaise des
policiers quand il s'en prend à une
candidate socialiste
évidemment que non pendant ce temps là
les commissaires les commissariats sont
dans un état de délabrement pas croyable
pendant ce temps là à guyancourt par
exemple une agglomération de 110 mille
habitants vous avez que deux voitures la
nuit pour faire la patrouille donc on
peut raconter tout ce qu'on veut
sécuritaire peines planchers etc
il ya moins de policiers aujourd'hui qui
en avait en 2007 à quoi à qui doit-on ça
valérie pécresse xavier bertrand nicolas
sarkozy françois fillon
ceux qui disaient non remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux donc moi je
prends pas de leçon de sécurité de la
part de la droite
mais qu'en pense que ce soit sur la
sécurité je réponds sur la sécurité
celles et ceux qui hurlent sécurité
sécurité sécurité
ce sont les mêmes qui ont supprimé la
police de proximité c'est à eux qu'on
doit le fait d'avoir moins de policiers
aujourd'hui onze mille de moins sous
mandat nicolas sarkozy
malgré tous les discours dix mille onze
mille policiers en moins ils ont
désorganisé les services de
renseignement ils ont refusé
ça c'est emmanuel macron le plan borloo
qui prévoyait le retour de la prévention
le retour d'adultes relais correspondant
nuit les marianne de la république la
présence des services publics dans les
quartiers
donc en fait ils ont complètement failli
et par ailleurs sur les féminines
vous avez vous savez qu'il ya un tiers
des homicides qui sont en fait
des féminicides c'est à dire des femmes
tuées par leur conjoint ou par leur ex
on considère que ça relève du privé dont
vous avez une droite l heure où l rer
qui considère que ça c'est privé et que
qui est pour moi complètement
disqualifié a parlé de sécurité quand
ils sont incapables de protéger la
moitié un peu plus de la population est
ce que est ce que tout ça ça fait partie
des sujets que vous avez évoqué hier
lors de la visioconférence que vous avez
tenus pour entre les différents
représentants des partis de gauche ou
pas du tout oui on a un peu discuté je
prends je constate que cette réunion
intéresse beaucoup
oui mais nous nous sommes concentrés sur
les régionales sur nationale c'était
essentiellement les régionales ah non
non non non non nous nous sommes
concentrés sur les régionales et cette
réunion elle avait pour but de 10 y aune
et le pacte du pouvoir de vivre qui est
un réseau en une coalition un une plate
forme organisée à l'initiative de la
cfdt de la fondation abbé pierre ou la
fondation pour la nature et pour l'homme
et qui propose des mesures de justice
sociale et d'investissement dans la
transition écologique la rénovation
thermique par exemple ça vous permet
vraiment de progresser ensemble il ya un
espoir d'aboutir un programme cots bien
sûr bien sûr bien sûr bien susan bien
sûr bien sûr non mais c'est trop tôt
surtout photo parce que l'enjeu
aujourd'hui ce sont les régionales
je pense que je comprends canton durant
deux tours des régionales ou
interrégionales parce que les régions
excusez moi je comprends que tout le
monde s'intéresse et soit passionné pour
la présidentielle évidemment c'est une
élection majeure c'est simplement une
présidentielle c'est une question de
fond de ce que la gauche a à proposer
aux français la gauche et les
écologistes vous nous dites que vous
avez parlé de la sécurité par exemple
qu'est-ce que vous êtes disent
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une fracture à
gauche sur ce qui intéresse non non il
n'y a pas de fracture détendez vous
vraiment je comprends que tout le monde
soit passionné par la présidentielle on
est un an de l'élection mais je
comprends c'est tout à fait normal
simplement l'élection prioritaire c'est
c'est pas une élection intermédiaire les
régionales on peut faire enlever pour la
transition écologique dans la justice
sociale
ce que le gouvernement a piétiné c'est à
dire les propositions de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat on peut les
traduire très concrètement en acte c'est
la rénovation thermique c'est des
emplois pour le tpe pour nos pme
vous pouvez avoir un emploi tous les
cinq à six logements rénovés et par
ailleurs pour les personnes qui peuvent
se chauffer correctement c'est même une
question de santé de bien-être de
dignité
les transports on a une souffrance en
particulier en ile de france
avec des transports qui sont pas fiables
pas ponctuelle pas sécurisé en fait sur
la question je suis à dix et que je suis
et je suis simplement fatigué que tout
le monde me parle de la présidentielle
alors que les régions peuvent beaucoup
tout le monde considère que l'après tout
le monde considèrent ces élections comme
une élection intermédiaire nous sommes
les seuls les écologistes et en
particulier en ile de france à
considérer que c'est une élection en
soit vous allez valérie pécresse qui
n'est pas capable de vous dire si elle
est candidate à la présidence de la
région ou à la présidence de la
république
nous sommes candidats et candidates et
nicolas thirion nouvelle aquitaine et
claire desmares en bretagne et karima
delli dans les eaux france nous sommes
candidats et candidates pour diriger ces
régions mais jean va on va parler bien
sûr des régionales mais pour finir sur
la gauche est ce pour quoi vous êtes un
peu mal à l'aise et que vous évacuer ces
sujets en dix ans d'abord il ya les
régionales et on verra la suite que la
suisse est apparu allait la voir dans
six semaines finalement étape par étape
nous avons des discussions au long cours
nous avons des réunions des changes
tout le monde veut savoir ce qui s'est
pas dit etc c'est pas vraiment le sujet
étape par étape les élections régionales
et départementales qu'on oublie
malheureusement trop souvent ensuite en
juillet nous nous adoptons notre socle
programmatique
donc c'est pour ça que c'est important
le cadre général que nous allons
proposer aux françaises et aux français
il fait il fait l'objet de beaucoup de
discussions dans les commissions les
personnes qui s'y intéressent des
experts une expertise citoyenne aussi et
des échanges avec les différentes forces
politiques ont été mentionnés en juillet
nous l'adoptons en septembre nous avons
une désignation démocratique une
primaire où les personnes qui
s'intéressent à l'écologie peuvent venir
voter choisir qui nous représentera
moyenne en mer de règne quoi qu'il
arrive ou la pierre il va dépendre du
résultat des régionales
elle est organisée elle a lieu en
septembre source s et j'aurais résultant
région juillet et une primaire en
septembre et ensuite nous proposons une
coalition large coalition aux forces qui
s'écologise aux forces qui sont capables
de soutenir cette cet arc humaniste ou
coalition pro-européenne féministe
écologiste humaniste avec un contrat de
mandature un accord aux législatives et
un contrat de gouvernement mais tout ça
s'organise étape par étape
si vous arrivez à contractualiser avec
les autres forces de gauche ça se fera
avec votre candidat celui qui sera ou
celle qui sera issu de vos primaires
tout à fait c'est le mandat que j'ai
reçu
quand j'ai été élu secrétaire national
en 2019 et depuis on déroule étape après
étape
je comprends qu'un ordre les âmes était
logique celle proposée par olivier faur
par exemple qui dit faisons d'abord
mettons nous d'abord sur un d'accord sur
un contrat un programme et puis ensuite
on verra qui est la meilleure
personnalité pour l'incarner si vous
vous choisissez moi je vous ai dit vous
disent que votre candidat je vous dis ce
que nous faisons je dis ce que je fais
j'ai fait ce que je dis et voilà ce que
nous proposons aux autres forces mais
encore une fois la méthodologie
viendront kg un désaccord non non sur ce
qui se passe au sein d'europe écologie
les verts par exemple hier eric piolle
il n'est pas venu à la réunion alors
qu'il était présent à la précédente à ce
que par exemple regretté cette absence
est est ce que vous avez un peu
l'impression qui fait les choses de son
côté puisqu'il dit moi je continue à
discuter avec les forces de gauche
oui et hausse à la fin cette réunion
s'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga par
ailleurs nous avons des réunions
bilatérales avec ses différentes forces
qu'on a mentionné de préparation des
discussions et tout l'enjeu c'est plutôt
l'automne donc encore une fois je
comprends que tout le monde soit très
pressé mais ces élections que tout le
monde qualifie d'intermédiaire pour nous
c'est des élections en soi et on va en
parler justement
et oui puisque vous parlez de discussion
et régional est ce que vous discutez
avec les autres têtes de liste de la
gauche en île de france par exemple
audrey pulvar clémentine autain est-ce
que vous avez est ce que vous est-ce que
vous bossez ensemble sur ce qui pourrait
être une future alliance alors en
échange de mesures sur les programmes
sont en échange très régulièrement mais
on n'est pas dans les parutions de
de près second tour ou quoi que ce soit
mais en échange vous en france pour
l'instant il n'empêche que vous avez des
échanges avec des siens sur quoi est ce
que vous pourriez vous vous rapprochez
facilement rassure l'écologie c'est
l'écologie qui peut rassembler savez
quand on propose la cristallisation des
aides par exemple le développement
économique est une compétence majeure de
la région en particulier quand il ya une
crise économique et sociale comme
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui valérie pécresse un peu
comme le mnr macron avec le cic e
finance finance sans contrepartie vous
pouvez par exemple nous a fait financer
renault à hauteur d'un million d'euros
alors qu'ils ont reçu 5 milliards par
ailleurs de l'état donc il semble pas
besoin c'est l'argent de poche comparé à
1,5 milliard dead est par ailleurs ils
licencient et ils suppriment lusine de
choisy le roi donc pour nous nous disons
écoutez c'est l'argent public pour
financer la pollution les licenciements
les délocalisations c'est non avec ce
million d'euros nous aurions pu financer
dix entreprises dix pme à son il y en a
beaucoup des pme des petites et moyennes
entreprises notamment en seine et marne
en val d'oise en grande couronne qui on
va avoir des difficultés à redémarrer
donc oui c'est un choix critéres ise ces
aides je le propose depuis dix ans en
commission développement économique sam
est systématiquement refusées
aujourd'hui c'est plébiscité par la
population
voilà seront là sont des 85% de les
écologistes trois quarts des socialistes
et même deux tiers à droite oui c'est
pour ça que je dis que l'écologie peut
très largement rassemblée et c'est ça
qui peut l'emporter parce qu'en fait
c'est le projet du 21e siècle lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique et
lutter contre les inégalités
est-ce que vous discuter du fond avec
elle parce que si vous vous rassemblez
on imagine que ça va être sur un
programme vous êtes le premier à dire
d'ailleurs le projet d'abord parlons du
fond est ce que par exemple elles se
sont engagées à reprendre votre
proposition vous avez présenté hier de
green new deal se plante dans les six
massifs pour transformer l'économie
francilienne
et est-ce que vous par exemple vous êtes
prêt à prendre à votre compte la
gratuité dans les transports qui est la
proposition phare d'audrey pulvar nous
faisons la tarification sociale n'y a
pas vraiment de gratuité comme vous le
savez il ya une solidarité
donc il ya un enjeu de tarification
sociale ya des personnes que je pense
notamment aux mineurs de moins de 18 ans
qu'on pas comparer au passe navigo
gratuit alors que les petits parisiens
ont lu le long
donc il s'agit est plutôt de l'étendre
il ya des retraités comparé accès aux
demi tarif il ya des tarifs ponctuelle
par i know you're no more comtoise qui
sont trop chers donc là il s'agit de les
plafonner
mais l'enjeu c'est l'investissement dans
les transports mais tout le monde est
d'accord là dessus le rer b le rer d
elles sont à moderniser d'urgence il
faut étendre des tramways vous avez une
question de sécurité nous réclamons
depuis six ans des brigades de
tranquillité dans les transports nous
réclamant une action face au harcèlement
dans les transports tout ça nécessite un
investissement que nous ne pouvons pas
mener si on met deux designers comme
analyste commune dans l'entre-deux-tours
vous ne porterez pas la gratuité dans
les transports
non nous porterons la tarification
sociale la gratuité par exemple pour les
services civiques qui sont aujourd'hui
une sorte de trou dans la raquette voyez
comme ils sont pas tout à fait salariés
ni étudiant ici payent plein tarif ça et
c'est injuste
évidemment il ya un enjeu
d'investissements dans les transports du
quotidien quand été délaissé par valérie
pécresse qu'elle ait promis 700
nouvelles rames
finalement il y en a 200 qui pour
l'essentiel ont été commandés par pierre
servent
vice président écologiste lors de la
mandature précédente 1 cd nouvelles
rames sur la ligne sur l'annuaire sur
les nuages nous nous agirons pour les
transports du quotidien le transport à
la demande par exemple il ya beaucoup de
zones rurales c'est à l'état balbutiant
aujourd'hui on peut mettre en place des
transports à la demande pour que chacun
chacune et accès à une offre de
transport à 15 minutes de chez soi voilà
l'enjeu
ça c'est la région qui peut agir et
voyez que quand on agit là dessus c'est
bon pour le climat évidemment mais c'est
aussi bon pour la santé pour le
bien-être le bilan là valérie pécresse
aujourd'hui c'est que huit cadres sur
dix plus de la moitié des franciliens et
des franciliens veulent partir de la
région
nous voulons changer cette logique
peut-être une dernière chose sur les
régionales vous avez des sondages là qui
sortent qui montre que finalement le le
le
le taux de mobilisation pour ces
élections pour être bien supérieur à ce
qu'on redoutait au départ qui aura pas
forcément une vague abstentionnistes
impressionnante
par contre on a l'impression qu'en fait
les électeurs vont plutôt soit soutenir
les présidents sortants soit allé voter
pour manifester un désaccord avec le
gouvernement en place et dans ce
scénario là entre soutien et
manifestations du désaccord on voit pas
très bien quelle est la place de
l'écologie ne vous êtes pas forcément
très belle dynamique dans les sondages
les prêts sondages
comment est-ce que vous l'expliquer en
fait mais on est très loin du compte
vous savez à un an des européennes on
était à 3% et l'avant veille c'est qu'il
ya une marge de progression très forte
possible dans le temps au temps là c'est
le temps de la campagne le temps
d'exposer un projet vous savez le green
new deal quand on présente trois
milliards d'investissements sur deux ans
qu'on explique que ça peut contribuer à
créer deux cent mille emplois dont
trente mille emplois tremplin pour les
associations la culture l'économie
sociale et solidaire
mais là les gens s'intéressent très
tardivement c'est comme ça moi je suis
en campagne depuis juillet et nous avons
vrai un rassemblement avec sept partis
politiques tout ça prend du temps avec
benoît hamon avec delphine batho avec
pierre larrouturou
tout ça prend du temps mais la campagne
ll malheureusement elle ne fait que
démarrer
de plus faire de terrain par exemple
aller rencontrer non ça c'est pas un an
dit non non bien au contraire en fait ça
a permis au contraire d'avoir des gens
plus curieux qui passe et une tête sur
un zoom pour regarder vous voyez au
moment où ils font leurs pas pour voir
si le sujet les intéressés il n'aurait
jamais poussé la porte de la salle des
fêtes de corbeil-essonnes où de savigny
sur orge en france au tractage sur les
marchés et rencontres directes ça ça
vous monte ça continue ça continue on va
regarder un autre sondage c'est le
sondage ifop paru hier sur les
les éventuels résultats en ile de france
il ya trois listes de gauche on l'a dit
vous êtes en tête des listes de gauche
mais d'une courte tête et surtout vous
franchissez à peine la barre des 10% est
ce que vous vous dites on est peut-être
en train de jouer un jeu dangereux qui
risque de nous éliminer
il faut pas ce qui compte c'est les
tendances si vous regardez les scores
des sondages vous êtes vous êtes menu
blier par les sondages ça peut pas
fonctionner ce qui est important c'est
les tendances et donc effectivement il
ya trois quatre cinq sondages de suite
qui nous met d'une courte tête vous
l'avais dit en pointe et c'est pour ça
que c'est l'écologie qui peut rassembler
je vous dis c'est l'écologie qui peut
arriver en tête au soir du premier tour
ça c'est le choix des électrices et des
électeurs et ensuite nous pouvons
proposer un large rassemblement et
l'emporter face à valérie pécresse c'est
l'écologie en dynamique qui permet
d'offrir une alternative à la situation
actuelle
sauf que vous êtes très proche de la
barre des 10% éliminatoires c'est une
inquiétude trouvé ça ça va ça va se
décanter encore une fois à 48 heures des
élections européennes on était
finalement à la moitié du score réalisé
tout simplement parce que on peut le
déplorer mais c'est normal les
électrices et électeurs se renseignent
tardivement en tout cas quand et
reçoivent les professions de foi quand
ils s'intéressent au projet et puis qui
essaient décide à ceux à voter pour les
compétences de la région
eh bien nous sommes les seuls ici à
faire campagne pour cette élection en
soi et non pas comme un prêt premier
tour je ne sais pas quoi justement un
dernier mot sur les régionales hors de
l'ile-de-france la vague verte à semble
un peu loin si on en croit les
différents sondages ya aucun écologiste
qui en mesure de remporter une région
comment vous l'expliquez mais nous
sommes en campagne
intéressez-vous aux projets aux
propositions que portent les écologistes
j'en ai cité quelques-uns c'est ça qui
fait la différence encore une fois
toutes les autres forces considère que
ces élections sont une élection
intermédiaire nous considérons ces
élections les régionales et
départementales pour ce qu' elle pour ce
qu'elles sont un outil pour la
transition écologique dans la justice
sociale pour créer des emplois verts
pour améliorer le bien-être pour
améliorer la santé pour tirer les leçons
de la crise sanitaire que que nous
verrez que nous vivons là pourquoi aux
électeurs ne sont pas répondre présent
eh bien on y vient attendait vont
constater des sondages nous faisons
campagne laisse un peu de temps aux
éclats région pour danser gagné position
quelle région si je vous dis
l'ile-de-france mes petits camarades me
dis que c'est pas très
fair play et je lui dis une autre plutôt
qu'une autre non moi je ne fais pas de
pronostics je suis en campagne
merci beaucoup julien bayou et puisque
vous êtes en campagne et qu'on est à un
mois du premier tour pour respecter
l'équité en vigueur en période de
campagne on va regarder l'ensemble des
têtes de listes dans votre région
ile-de-france où vous êtes candidat et
on va regarder à une de ouest france
aussi stéphane construction le béton
cherche encore sa transition écologique
ça devrait vous plaire s'agit un maillot
que la bretagne devrait perdre de
transition écologique absolument
nécessaire merci beaucoup et on tient à
claire des marins merci savard était
notre invité
[Musique]